nature the most powerful creative force
on Earth
[Music]
I'm Chef Melissa King cooking has taken
me to incredible places magical
TV competitions and celebrity Galas to
countries around the world
and heading out to places I've never
been before to seek out new experiences
and to create new dishes inspired by
Nature wow
floors to go further than I've ever gone
before this is insane stunning to push
craft creativity and my cooking
this is tasting Wild
[Music]
we are here just outside of Port Angeles
Washington on the northern coast of the
Olympic Peninsula
it's a really picturesque area
there's an incredible Forest that hits
this dramatic ocean coastline
I'm here to meet Anan Varma who shoots
incredible photos of nature
his photography and work really shows
details that I've never seen before
[Music]
I'm meeting him at an apiary
a farm that I heard produces an
extremely unique honey
hello hey honey so nice to meet you
Melissa how are you doing great doing
great have you ever worn a bee suit
before I have not all right first all
right I just wanted to do this yeah this
is going to be your suit let's get
suited up and check out what's going on
here cool one of the early stories I
worked on for National Geographic was on
honeybees and I actually kept a beehive
in my backyard and that let me kind of
study their lives you get up close and
you take the time to pay attention and
you realize how much Beauty and
complexity is all around us everywhere
you look have you ever looked inside a
beehive before no first time I've been
to Apiaries but first time being able to
like get up close I'm curious of the
flavor profile I love honey I cook with
honey all the time but to be able to
like get up close and personal I'm
excited can't wait to taste this honey
I've heard great things about it yeah I
haven't tried it yet
bye
hello this is Dan and Judy Harvey we've
been here since 1985.
and when you have healthy bees in the
right weather conditions they make a lot
of honey
are you ready for this Melissa yeah I'm
super excited so one of the really cool
things about this area is this native
plant called Fireweed and so what Dan
and Judy have done is set up their hives
so that the bees are almost exclusively
collecting the nectar and pollen from
this one kind of plant this native plant
Fireweed doesn't have a lot of
pesticides or herbicides sprayed on it
so that means that the honey is super
clean it's super pure and it's all
coming from a single flower so it has a
unique flavor profile wow that's what
I'm curious about is the flavor notes of
the Fireweed and what makes it unique
and special
I can tell from Melissa's work she's
somebody who pays really close attention
to her craft and so as somebody who's
that tuned in I'm really curious what
kinds of things she'll pick up on here
so if you'd like to see a queen this is
going to be the quickest way to see it
the king needs to meet her Queen
each box is a different Queen
each box is a different Queen you can
see the pollen that's all pollen right
there oh yeah this is the honey the
nectar and the pollen's all one color
and you can tell that they're just can
you flip it over and just set it here
I'd love to take a picture so that's a
great idea
when I decided to become a photographer
macro photography became my specialty
nature is kind of the ultimate
inspiration to keep exploring and to
keep discovering new details it's so
surprising when you get up close to a
honeybee especially its face you realize
they're like covered in fur there's
hairs coming out of their eyeballs you
learn to appreciate them in a whole new
way
Honey comes in a wide range of flavors
you can really use it from Savory dishes
to Sweet dishes it's almost like wine
there's so many different nuances that
you can get from a single honey
this is incredible I love seeing all the
bees on here and what they're doing
let's go taste some money okay let's go
that was so cool
it was amazing I think there's something
really unique about Fireweed honey
oh wow
I dip my finger in there it's so good
yeah it's very light but also very clean
tasting it's so delicate and flavor
profile
we thank you for coming it's been a
pleasure it's always exciting to have
somebody come who's interested enough to
want to know more details well we'll see
you hopefully again all right thanks so
much
that bee farm was incredible yeah I
think what they're doing is really cool
leaving the apiary Onan tells me we're
going to investigate a tide pool it's
one of my favorite things to do I've
tied pulled around the coast of
California and up through Oregon but
never this far north
Seafood so much it's one of my favorite
ingredients to work with and I'm just
excited to explore this area and see if
there's mussels or Barnacles maybe even
clams that we can find I can't wait to
show you what's in there
there's this island it's surrounded by
tide pools tons of cool little stuff in
those pools
I think bird which is just incredible to
be able to capture that type of detail
so what got you into macro photography
I think it was just what I did as a kid
I would like head out the back door in
my childhood home in Atlanta and I'd
head down to the creek in my backyard
and you know it was like every time you
you pull up a rock or or turn over a log
there'd be some weird little bug or a
snake or or salamander then somewhere
along the way I fell in love with
exploring the natural world and I found
out that photography could be this way
of sharing my discoveries with other
people
every time I've ever been tide pooling I
see a creature I've never seen in my
life that's one of the rewards of paying
close attention you spend the time to
look at something carefully and you get
to discover something new and it
motivates you to keep going
so we are in a pretty special spot where
the tide has pulled out and it's going
to allow us to explore a lot more than
what we'd be able to see any other time
of day
I'm hoping to really tie in all the
ingredients that we find in this tide
pool into a dish
insane stunning yeah yeah all right so I
think we got to pick our way down this
kind of Cliff here
we're making our way down these rocks
and I see mussels Barnacles starfish wow
look at all the seaweed
look at this kombu have you ever
harvested your own absolutely yeah you
can dry all this and use it for any sort
of applications from brats to soups oh
cool there's so much life here to
explore you see a rock covered in
mussels and then you get down to one of
those muscles and it's covered in
limpets and like that Limpet has its own
algae and there's just these you know
levels upon levels of detail and life
and biodiversity and that's what makes
tide pools so special
wow this is so cool
whoa hey what what is that they're just
picking out look at how much it's moving
dinosaur
that's from the wild
you can't kind of see there's a big rock
in the cave but we name it for the left
side of that
I think that's good Tide's coming in
already yeah it's fast
we start turning rocks here I think
there's some cool stuff to find yeah
it's like a starfish
like a baby baby starfish
oh my God I have never seen this before
what is that
wow there's so many colors and creatures
here to explore and it's really endless
I'm feeling inspired by all the layers
that are being revealed it makes me
think about my own cooking and the
layers within food look at this
it's a sea star what they call these
blood Stars no way
look at that color
[Music]
the Tide's coming in but I want to go
look for some clams on the beach
[Music]
I can't believe we were just out there
it's surrounded by water now it's like
you've got to take a boat to get to
where we were
what are we looking for so um you just
kind of start raking when you see little
bubbles like that there might be some
from there that's what happens so you'll
find cockles little Nicks oh whoa what's
that what's that we've got
cool all right
got some little necks
it's gonna be tasty
but yeah these are going to be great for
steaming okay A little necks I think
we'll do some sort of uh tomka or some
sort of steamed clam and muscle fish I
think
as we're headed back to the car we find
some beautiful looking sea beans which
I'd love to include in my dishes somehow
give it a try it tastes like the ocean
oh wow
it's like a salty pickle almost exactly
yeah
the details we saw today at the Aviary
and along the coast were astonishing I
can't wait to integrate all the flavors
we found into a meal for Onan tomorrow
okay we're almost there I'm so excited
for you to see this spot on the coast
that I found awesome yeah yeah it's
really beautiful it's gonna be great to
be able to cook out on the beach we're
gonna set up some live fire do a little
cookout so while you're setting up I'd
love to create a little field studio and
I'll shoot some of the ingredients I'll
get some close-ups of the mussels in
particular they look really cool up
close I'd love to see that
right here we are
wow this is gorgeous what a day huh
beautiful all right let's grab some
stuff from the trunk all right I'm gonna
get the kitchen started over on the
beach okay and get the fire started
awesome
one of the most exciting Parts about
photography is getting to see this
pattern or detail that you didn't notice
at first glance you zoom in with the
macro lens and you take a picture and
it's that moment where you see something
on the back of the camera that you never
noticed before all right the fire's
rolling whoa what's Happening Here check
this out look at this little muscle I
zoom way in here
look at that oh my goodness isn't that
crazy
muscles all the time but I've never seen
it like this before right that's a
barnacle huh
so cool
this is incredible work oh thank you
stunning
well are you ready to make some dinner
with me all right that sounds great
let's go
all right here we are oh my God it's
pretty beautiful right oh wow
I hope Onan notices the details of the
sea beans kombu all the ingredients that
we've harvested together
I also really want to find a place for
Dan and Judy's honey I wanted to tell a
story I want him to taste those flavors
and be reminded of where we are we're
making a Szechuan chili butter oysters
that are grilled with a little bit of
that honey that we picked up earlier and
we're also doing a tomka I can't believe
her start with these Szechuan chili
butter Wood Fire Grilled oysters with
honey we're gonna cook them right on
that fire
you want really high heat okay that's
what's going to get them caramelized
it'll cook really quickly within a
minute or so now we're cooking here we
go that's our appetizer number one Wow
Let's see how it's nice golden brown
around the edges it was just bubbling
cheers thanks so much Melissa
[Music]
it's incredible it's incredible thank
you
don't waste the liquor
so I'll be making you a Tome mussels and
clams sort of tide pool inspired soup
all right oh wow let's go with the clams
and the mussels you can throw all that
in
almost gonna break up this lemongrass
this is also a key component
to a tomcat wow okay all right let's
throw some sake in wow a little bit of
stock
and then some coconut milk okay key
ingredient to a tomka this Cooks pretty
quick just right when they open it's
catching it at that right moment the
second they open that's when we're gonna
pull this off the stove all of these
ingredients we gathered here and it
really is just concentrating down into
this one pot couldn't get more local
than this right all right I'm going to
bring this over to the table and we'll
plate up over there okay
as I'm layering this in I I want this to
look like the tide pool I wanted to
resemble the place that we went together
basil cilantro sea beans that oh yeah
together and a big squeeze of lime oh
wow
that is our tomka okay all the shellfish
that we got together so bring that over
there all right
with some ice cream tea
ah thank you so much great thank you so
much this is hi Nature's dining room
right it's not every day you get to do
this with a professional chef and a
beautiful place and delicious beautiful
looking food hopefully be a memorable
moment for you as much as it is for me
believe me you've succeeded this is
going to be I'm gonna remember this for
a long time thank you
these moments are all about connection
and food is something that brings
everyone together being able to be here
like literally on the beach eating
together is such a special moment so
thank you for that oh thank you for the
adventures to the tide pools
[Music]
I came to the Olympic Peninsula looking
for sweeping views along the vast
Coastline
what I discovered was the beauty and all
the little things
and how important it is to look closer
keep exploring
take in the amazing details of the world
around us
[Music]